-President Biden
is back from his summit
with Russian president
Vladimir Putin,
and now the very same people
who approved of
Donald Trump's
friendly attitude toward Putin
are claiming Biden
wasn't tough enough.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
President Biden has returned
from his first overseas trip,
which, once again, showed the
stark contrast between
his presidency
and that of Trump.
Even Putin himself
was willing to acknowledge
the difference
in this exchange with reporters.
-The conversation
was quite constructive.
And I once again understood
that President Biden
is an experienced statesman.
He is very different
from President Trump.
-I mean, to be fair,
everybody is.
Putin's like a kid describing
his mom's new boyfriend.
"Yeah, she dumped Sammy 'cause
he got fired from Guitar Center
for eating Slim Jims on the job
and spending all day
playing the solo from
'In the Air Tonight'
on the drum kit,
and now she's out with Keith.
He's a dentist
who collects stamps.
He's very different.
The other day, we had salad!"
It's weird to hear that
description come from Putin
of all people.
Although, I bet his
relationship with Trump was
less like buddy-buddy
and more like
former KGB agent
and useful moron.
Like, Putin obviously
preferred Trump policy-wise,
but there's got to be
a small part of him
that's relieved not to have
to make small talk with Trump
anymore in those long
one-on-one meetings.
I mean, Trump
is like your weed dealer
who drops off a baggie and
then won't leave.
"I'm just gonna roll one up
before I get an Uber.
So, anyway, Vlad, it's 1986,
and I'm at Studio 54
with Tommy Lee
and Wally Backman.
Bad guy, nasty guy.
Nice to me, though.
He was in a platoon
with Tim Teufel.
Do you remember Tim Teufel?"
"I do not know this Teufel man."
"Well, the 'Late Night'
crew remembers him,
I promise you that.
You can bend John O'Malley's ear
about Tim Teufel.
He'd be happy to fill you in."
So, even Putin
was willing to admit that
he was dealing with a more
experienced statesman, in Biden.
Our key allies in
the G7 and NATO
also seemed excited
throughout Biden's trip
about the fact that they were
finally dealing with
a U.S. president interested in
global cooperation
to solve common problems.
And, yet --
this will shock you --
Fox News had
a very different takeaway.
-Unfortunately,
we've seen a lot of weakness
from President Biden
as it relates to Russia.
-Vladimir received
a massive platform
in exchange for
zero concessions whatsoever.
And Putin then
used that platform
to take shot after shot after
shot at our country,
the United States of America.
Joe, of course, was nowhere to
be found correcting the record,
because he was afraid
to stand next to Vladimir,
probably because he
is not capable of doing it.
-It makes us look ridiculous.
It is embarrassing.
-I thought The Washington Post
had a great line, too.
It said -- And I don't even know
if they were being --
they knew they were
being funny, I think.
They say, "Joe Biden's
pessimistic approach
to the summit
seems to have paid off."
Fantastic!
So I had low expectations
and I hit all my goals.
-Thank God the two of them
didn't stand next each other.
You know, Joe Biden is
a kindly old man,
and he looked tired
and he didn't have vigor.
Compare that to Putin,
who is a killer,
who does have
the wind at his back.
-Okay, I compared them.
Am I supposed to be on
Team Killer?
I mean, that sounded
like something
Samantha would say
when comparing lovers.
"I don't have time
for kindly old men.
I need a killer
with the wind at his back.
And my back!"
Also, this idea that, somehow,
Biden comes off as tired
just because he doesn't use
his press conferences
to rant and rave for hours about
insane [bleep] is so stupid.
I mean, Trump is the one
who constantly looked exhausted
and drained of energy,
because he spent all his time
screaming at reporters
and pulling all-nighters
to hate-watch cable news.
I mean, look at him.
He looks like an old umpire
at the end of a July
Little League doubleheader,
and you guys
are complaining that Biden
didn't do a joint
press conference
with Putin to correct him?
Trump did a joint
press conference with Putin,
and all he did
was agree with him.
When those two did
a press conference together,
Trump was basically Putin's
Ed McMahon.
"Russia had nothing to do
with election hacking,
and anyone who disagrees will be
sent to the Slauson Cut-Off,
where we will
cut off their Slauson."
[ Laughs ] "Very good!"
Now, Biden's summit with Putin
was a tricky balancing act.
On the one hand, you want to
hold Putin accountable
for his actions,
but on the other,
you don't want it to
escalate into conflict,
as Biden explained.
-When you run a country
that does not abide by
international norms,
and, yet, you need those
international norms
to be somehow managed
so that you can participate
in the benefits
that flow from them,
it hurts you.
That's not a satisfying answer.
"Biden said he'd invade Russia."
You know, it is not --
You know...
By the way, that was a joke.
That's not true.
-Thanks for clarifying,
but, also, no more jokes.
Especially after
meeting with Putin.
That's the last place we need
you to workshop new material.
But I understand and appreciate
the point Biden was making.
Diplomacy can be complicated.
We can hold Putin accountable
for his actions
and avoid conflict with Russia,
which no one wants.
I mean, I don't know if 30 Rock
even has a bomb shelter,
but if it does, I don't want to
get stuck down there
with Wally, the two of us eating
canned beans in our underwear
for the rest of our lives,
while he holds up cue cards,
asking me if I want to
play Scrabble.
And then, when we run out of
food, we open the hatch,
only to find out it had
been a false alarm.
And bad news -- we've
been underground for 17 years.
But good news --
we're back just in time for
the Broadway revival
of my musical,
"Cicada, Cicada,"
with it's original cast --
Baranski, Fierstein, Lane,
and Jason Sudeikis
in the role of Jason Cicadas.
And for those of you wondering
what role that is,
I'd describe it as kind of
like -- I don't know --
the stage manager in
"Our Town."
He kind of just walks you
through the action.
His first line is,
"Oh, I didn't see you there."
The point is,
we can hold Putin accountable
for election interference
and human-rights abuses
while also avoiding
a tense confrontation
with a nuclear-armed power,
and Biden did his best
to walk a fine line.
That doesn't mean
he didn't make mistakes.
For example,
while he was talking about
Russian election interference,
he said this.
-How would it be if the
United States were viewed by
the rest of the world as
interfering with the elections,
directly, of other countries
and everybody knew it?
-How would it be? Hold on.
Let me consult this thing
I found the other day.
It's called a book.
And let me see.
And oh, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, Joe, you do not want
to read this.
I mean, seriously, dude,
you can condemn Putin
for interfering in our elections
and colluding with Trump
to subvert our democracy without
ignoring our own history.
I mean, one study found that
the U.S. has intervened
in foreign elections more than
80 times, worldwide,
between 1946 and 2000.
80 times!
The U.S. has intervened
in foreign elections
almost as many times as
we've played that
stupid Vanilla Ice clip.
-Uh, like, it goes, "Ding, ding,
ding, ding-a-ding, ding.
Ding, ding, ding,
ding-a-ding, ding."
That's the way theirs goes.
Ours goes, "Ding, ding, ding,
ding-a-ding, ding.
Tshh, ding, ding, ding,
ding-a-ding, ding."
That little, bitty ting.
It's not the same.
-We had to do it.
If we do it three times,
we get a free sub
made by Vanilla Ice.
And, by the way, we've heard
feedback from some of you guys
that we went to
the well too many times on
the Vanilla Ice clip,
while others seem to be
enjoying it a great deal.
So, we want to know
what you think.
Please go to @seacaptainpolls
and vote for
"stop," "collaborate,"
or "listen."
The point is,
both things can be true.
We can be honest about
our own past
while also standing up
to election interference
and human-rights abuses by
brutal autocrats like Putin.
In fact,
learning from our own past
and striving to be better
is a good thing.
Trump and his cronies are the
ones who have been cozying up
to dictators, working to
subvert our democracy,
and actively trying to
whitewash our own history
by censoring teachers or
rewriting textbooks.
The GOP has taken
a hard turn against democracy,
and two polls published
this week have found that
Putin has a better
net favorable rating
among Republicans than Biden
does, which is insane.
Trump himself
never seemed happier
than when he was
meeting with dictators.
He always had that rictus grin
like the clown at the end
of the mini-golf course.
It's all a part of the GOP's
growing contempt for democracy
and their open attempts
to subvert our elections.
And now another
new poll found that
more than half of
GOP voters actually believe
the big lie that
Republicans keep spreading
about the 2020 election.
-A new poll out today
says that more than half --
more than half --
of Republican voters
think election reviews
will change the 2020 outcome.
-I mean, it's been seven months,
and they still think
Trump's going to come back
because they trust
a pillow magnate more than
the sanctity of our elections.
At some point, you just
have to accept an outcome
that you don't agree with
and say,
"It's Bran, and we can't do
anything about it."
Sidenote,
speaking of elections --
I voted early for
New York mayor yesterday
and I was incredibly impressed
by how seriously they took it.
For example, when they
asked for my signature,
I just scribbled it
the way you'd sign
a credit-card receipt,
and they said,
"This isn't a match."
And I said,
"Do you know who I am?
I wrote 'Cicada, Cicada.'"
And they said, "Prove it."
And I said...
♪ 17 years with my head
in the mud ♪
♪ And my heart in my throat ♪
♪ And my wings that
are yearning to fly ♪
And then they kicked me out.
And I said, "Your loss,
'cause I was voting for
de Blasio again."
The point is,
if the GOP gets the chance
to overturn an election
in the future,
they could very well do it.
I mean, what if they
win back the House in 2022
and then Biden
wins re-election in 2024?
Do you really think Republicans
will suddenly regain
their sanity?
I mean, I was trapped in a room
with a sea-captain painting
for a few months, and when I
returned to the studio,
it's not like
I immediately became sane again.
I mean, sure, I didn't bring
the painting with me,
but I talk to Wally
all the time,
and now he's so famous
that he just got asked to do
a "Carpool Karaoke."
-♪ Fresh new kicks ♪
♪ And pants ♪
♪ You gotta like that ♪
♪ Now you know you wanna dance ♪
-They're gonna
let you do that song?
-Oh, yeah.
They said they could
afford to play it
as many times as I want.
-I'd like to apologize to
all our viewers,
from London to the Bay.
That's the central theme of
our politics right now.
The GOP has taken
a hard turn against democracy
and they've been open
about their attempts
to subvert our elections.
And that's why we need to be
honest about the crisis
we're faced with and pass laws
that preserve voting rights,
among other things.
As we end this segment tonight,
I'm mindful of the fact
that we've already used
Vanilla Ice
as the callback clip twice
this week, and I assure you,
we will not
do it again, because...
-It makes us look ridiculous.
It is embarrassing.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
-"Ding, ding, ding,
ding-a-ding, ding.
Tshh, ding, ding, ding,
ding-a-ding, ding."
-When you weren't expecting it.
[ Laughter ]
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men, women,
and children living with
HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "Donate" button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.